TRIP THAN GOING TONIPEG,
MATCHWORK LINEUP, ORR DYLAN DeM.
SCHMIDT WAS
PIERRE-LUC DUBOIS, GOT THAT ONE
IN, DOWN LOW. HAD A GREAT
SCORING CHANCE THERE LIKELY COUN
THE NET AND HE GOT A LITTLE BIT
OF PRESSURE THERE FROM
OF THE SAGINAW SPIRIT IS HERE
TONIGHT TO SEE COLE PERFETTI AND
A THERER FROM
MICHIGAN.
MICKEY: WELL,, ANDBE THE BELLE E
DAYS
AND, OH, MY, H H THERE ON LARKIN
HE GOT THAT PASS.
KEN: WITH
LARKIN, THE SHOT.
AND
SMARTLY BY SEIDER, THAT
FOR A CROSS-CHECK.
AND MORRISSEY, RAYMOND, BACK FOR
KYLE CONOR AND CANNOT BE SERI NS
FORMER TEAMMATE WITH DEFENSEMAN
CAME N AND IT IS NOT A ZADINA.
SUTER, BEHIND THE NET.
CHECKED.
AND THE JETS THERE FROM CONOR
AND THE FOUR WINGS JERSEYS, YOU
CAN SEE THEM, DOWN THE GREAT
QUIET FOR SEVEN MORE BUT HE HAS
NINE GOALS AND 23 POINTS ZONE
REDIRECT AND WHAT A SAVE MADE BY
NEDELIJKOVIC.
MICKEY: WELL, RAYMOND, BERTUZZIA
LONG-RANGE SAVE THERE FROM GETT.
PUCK LOOSE. BLOCKERSIDE OF TO TE
GOAL, SHOT, SAVE MADE, ANOTHER
STOP, THAT TIME
TO THE SIDE.
IN FRONT, TO THE EMPTY NET.
FOR THE HAT IT.
FOR ZADINA.
SUTER, FROM SHELBY
TOWNSHIP AND HE